welcome to this video for round 13
coverage of the candidates tournament
the penultimate round and this is a game
between Peter Svidler playing white and
sharqeyah mamedyarov playing black to
sum up the players standings villa is on
a minus one score he had lost this
pretty drastic game against Apollo right
before the rest day and mamedyarov is on
fifty percent so he's at least
theoretically it still got a chance to
qualify with him winning two games are
not losing two games so it's it's very
theoretical really but um well it's also
about about about rating and it's also
about money it's not just a place the
first place is obviously the big one but
well second place and and seventh place
is so close in this in this field that
it's always interesting to try to get it
I actually failed to find the exact
prices but I know that that they get
there is a substantial difference
between second place third place and and
seventh place like a couple of ten
thousands of dollars so it's really a
substantial if someone has a link to
that I couldn't find it i just tried it
for a couple of minutes and and didn't
find the list of prices strangely enough
okay so let's go through this game got
the night off which seems to be my
maduro's preparation for the tournament
this is already his um Wow third night
off I think I remember at least two he
played it against Vichy and against to
pull off both games ending in a draw
with
with h3 the new main line butts with
lies deviating he plays Bishop e3 which
is probably the the main line of the
1990s and early 2000s only 2000s I
recently caught some expressions form
for this if you say 80's 90's and then
the someone's had no cheese or something
like that like a well I don't know for
most of the time let's say we should be
three was the main line in the last last
20 years um with Bishop g5 also being
popular on and off after Bishop e3 the
black as a number of options of course
king hwy 64 asked ravening and type of
setup a five boys got them a very direct
way to play Knight g4 and yeah this has
a step has some it's now established as
one of blacks main answers just
attacking this bishop and provoking a
reaction Bishop g5 is the way to go and
now h6 and g5 yeah I sometimes wonder if
you look at those modern openings what
people like Stein it saw tirage would
have thought about it black is playing
let's say he's playing c-51 move one
which you know okay it wasn't
established opening back then but well
IFIF was far more more normal then move
like a six hmm very very strange and
then Black is moving the night twice and
pushing the kingside pawns it's very
strange I guess would have been very
strange for player so let's say 100
years ago but nowadays some we have
established that Black has some very
good to concrete play with this bishop
of course the very strong piece and he's
got the the square e 5 for its pieces of
course
ski for the night and g5 is securing
this the spot because f4 has suffered to
play yeah I'm here there are many
possible lines I actually thought that
age 3 is the main line here nowadays
it's played that quite often but there
is also Bishop e2 which spindler place
now is I think probably the old main
line which was for example played a
number of times against Kasparov who
really was a pioneer of the system age 5
must be played and now each form yeah
this isn't a word idea i believe 83 is
also a move here which is very strongly
answered by h form very important motif
to remember from whites point of view
this is already quite ugly yeah let's
say you take here black is going to kept
capture on g3 and the problem is if you
would recapture look at this position
just give up a PCM besides a it's very
ugly so h3 is not possible anymore white
can actually take here this is what was
played a couple not f4 was played a
couple of times against Kasparov for
instance by are not enter ends will I
recall games of that ok H form and like
is attacking the d4 night which
retreated and now to con each form which
is basically forced you cannot really
protect on g5 so we need to capture I
hope it should be six so what does black
hair for the somewhat strange structure
on the King side yeah or piece is active
night active both bishops and this night
they're all positioned in an active
negative way and it's not clear how
white should increase any sort of
pressure let's say against the h5 porn
so it's it's fine it's a fine balance of
activity yep queen is also employed
actively on b6 and this also makes it a
bit difficult for white now to to do
anything with the skin short canceling
really a bit weird gem so you would
consider if castle long but there's just
f2 hanging you cannot do that you also
cannot play a 3 oops very ugly move for
white and here black ass is already
winning I guess yeah it's a bit a bit
tricky to get get your king in two
safeties will deplete 95 which is also
still known territory they both played
this really quickly okay taken night to
deform this must be taken as well so we
are nearing an end game pretty quickly
c3 and back to f6 yeah in term here the
question is what should why do now this
is obviously a little bit of a standoff
between those two bishops yeah y term
castle first and yeah here that's just
really one weakness on black sir part
the h5 porn what he's doing now is just
playing a king to the seven and he
accepts um yeah an alteration of the
pawn structure which looks a bit ugly at
first and we'll we're going to see that
check the game took on g4 with the check
and now took one of six why did so we
have this structure it at first looks
really ugly yeah but it's not really a
big problem if you look at this in a bit
more more detail you see that those
pawns in the in the middle of the board
this ponds IAM can always relatively
easily be protected by the king only
seven for example this especially
applies if you trade one pair of rooks
and g form is very often just protected
by a five it's a very compact structure
of course white has some sort of
symbolic advantage because of yeah his
pawn structure being being a bit neater
but
there is really not so much going on
here it will also be beneficial for wide
in a way if you would have the pawn on
d4 back but okay you cannot move points
bounce backwards d phi f kin can be a
weakness sometimes if black managers for
example to a Tekkit let's say from g5
yeah in the game we had this rook trade
and rock before this was a pretty good
try at least to try to do something
against the g4 porn yeah here the
counter-attack as I mentioned on the
fifth-ranked you can counter-attack
against against e5 yeah invitin white
now could take here but after that it's
a it's really a bit pointless yeah y
term can claim okay I've got to pawn
islands you got three but no no way ever
this is not going to end in a draw um oh
they actually played that I'm sorry I I
looked at the wrong line of my of my
notes they actually played that and I'm
back to I'm actually giving the result
of the game away to be honest but here
is simply not nothing happening here
check got a couple of yeah what what you
what you need to be very cautious about
yes of course rook trades yeah even if
white would trade here black can fix the
spawn structure that's okay but what
black definitely not should do shouldn't
do is to trade himself this can easily
lose the game I actually didn't analyze
it because it's a it's frankly speaking
pretty ridiculous to exchange but I can
just hear quickly check if this is
really losing it probably should lose ya
g4 is a good move fixing those two and
you always have these kind of reserved
temples maybe
from d5 you can just go here and the
problem is that at some point the king
will move and then you will get getting
this yeah it's it's a lost King opponent
game so this is of course a very
important thing to remember if you win
aruba endgame and you have the chance to
go to a king opponent get this needs to
be very very carefully considered
because the King opponent game always
has a somewhat let's say a definite
evaluation it is a draw or win for one
side it's not like slightly better in
some cases is simply not exist in the
king and born and games it has a
mathematically clearly defined result or
evaluation which is just a window or
draw and enroute kent game some you
sometimes really applique you have those
those cases where one side is really
slightly better and can try and try and
try but probably won't get anywhere and
here it's a completely ridiculous from
blacks point of view to even consider
the Rope trade because you just move it
away and absolutely nothing will ever
happen so be very careful with the game
into a king and porn and game this is
actually the most um the type of endgame
transition that it's very often turning
badly wrong if you if you are not not
yeah not not careful them okay so they
played a couple of moments check but
there's basically nothing happening okay
here they agree to a draw yeah certainly
a game that right out of the opening
because all this seems to be a yeah
theoretically known it sort of drifted
to to position where nothing much what's
happening what I actually did admit
while going through that I'm sorry about
that in this position of course we see
that mamedyarov to
and then took on before with the Queen
there is this mu that you briefly could
check attacking the rook but white can
play a rookie one and there is simply
not much not much happening maybe he was
actually considering to take with the
bishop this is the possible move but I
is it any good f2 was hanging him this
is matt is quite interesting it is quite
interesting yeah maybe whiter one needs
to cancel on him which is not what wide
was probably thinking off in the first
place canceling short but ok black does
not have a safe place for his King as
well this would have been much sharper
actually but ok quindi for was the
conservative move that basically by
force almost led to this this end game
yeah ok so not the most exciting game
ever but we had plenty of excitement in
the tournament earlier especially if you
consider yeah well you cannot really say
that there's a big difference here
between both players here in this game
but this will add and really roller
coaster tournament with losses wins and
blunders and everything in there and
Mammadyarov overcame I mean look at his
games he was on minus 2 at the start
looked like he might end up like a job
of last year going to have a terrible
tournament and then he started to win
games and if he would would have won his
game against chronic which was winning
he would have been on +1 and be a well
really really close on on on on some
islands trails are very very exciting
tournament for both players alright
thanks for watching